this kind
the family has been making butter for a very
long time since my grandfather was a
butter maker then butter and not
just imports in fact an
icon food of brittany
[Music]
yes still possible and newspass at
low tide chaps and black makes butter to
Germans
so there are three stops
mainly the ouaka but the sweet and
the sea lettuce
there is one that comes from rancid
otherwise the other seaweed comes from
rostov and the iroise sea
we were the first to go up  the euro
dale begg smith
georges
frêche made a funny thing knowing that one
of the greatest chefs in the
world is sincerely interested in your work
is
something moving on the one hand  and secondly
which is interesting and important
since it obliges you to become
excellent I had the chance to arrive at
a time when the French butter makers had
abandoned table butter all our
butter is shaped by hand with
palettes and I  my working method has
enabled the great French chefs to
put butter back on the table while
I have returned to an
ultra artisanal production series 1
[Music]
a powerful iodized taste you know when
you eat seaweed butter I
invite you to close the  eyes
eating butter in the markets it's a
walk along the water with your
feet in the water butter is a
mud amplifier it allows a
dish to take on a whole
different universe touching it with my hands there's
nothing  I don't know anything more
sensual than death
except my wife
[Music]